hi there steve again here on my 90 day
challenge
i got to keep going you know
language learning is an endurance sport
it's a long distance event it's not a
sprint
and some days you're more motivated some
days you are
your enthusiasm flags a bit
some days you have more time
so it's important like any long distance
or endurance event it's important that
you stay with it so i'm going to talk a
little bit about how i managed to stay
with it yesterday i went to cooking
school as i said i did a bunch of stuff
around the house didn't do much
uh today
uh
today i did more like i added today 309
known words so i know for example that
again to step back i know that i'm
committed to 90 days of activity that
doesn't mean that i'm committed to
achieving any particular result i said
that at the beginning i'm going to
commit to this level of activity because
i know that with this level of activity
i will improve how much i improve
that will depend i don't know i can't
predict that so i have to maintain my
level of activity
so today because i didn't do much
yesterday today
i added 300 known words to my known
words total just by working on some
content in link
uh i created 158 links that i saved 158
words and phrases
uh whereas yesterday i'm looking at my
statistics here at link by the way so if
i look at yesterday i only added 60
known words to my total
and i only created
24 links you know so i was much more
active today than yesterday but still
there comes a point i can't just keep
pushing i've had it
so i did a few other things for example
i was going to go and have my workout
and you know get on my stepper and all
that and i really didn't want to hear
any more korean i've done so much korean
i'm reaching that saturation point so i
said you know what because i'm
interested in cooking it would be fun to
listen to some
podcasts on cooking in some other
language
so i went to my computer and i googled
podcast cuisine podcast kofina for
spanish podcast cucina italian
it is amazing the quality of podcasts
that are available so i decided to
download a french podcast i can't
remember what the name of it was now you
can look it up but
and so i was listening to people talking
about in fact georgian wines they were
talking about wines in georgia how
there's such a tremendous variety of
grapes there and they use amphoras to
store the wine and it was just totally
interesting and they have a very long
tradition and stuff and i'm hearing all
of this in french i would have preferred
maybe to hear about cooking or something
but still it was interesting and he was
a a diversion it kind of refreshes me
uh but tomorrow i got to get back on my
target so my point is it's a long
it's a long road you have to keep
yourself motivated like i set myself
very specific targets in terms of levels
of activity i also allow myself to
divert into other things the other thing
that's interesting is of course is
having put the effort into learning
french and italian and spanish
now i'm able to go in and enjoy podcasts
on cooking or history or whatever the
day may come
when korean won't be such a
you know a deliberate sort of struggle
for me i'll be maybe into arabic and
i'll divert back to korean and listen to
how they make kimchi but those are the
delights of of of learning languages and
keeping it varied so that you don't burn
out okay thanks for listening bye for
now